this cat lady burning down her house and
then I just think about it and I'm just
like
maybe we just need some hard times man
I think we'll all be fine I think
everybody who listens to a show like
this is probably fine we got so many
people who are like look I bought
chickens I got got out of the city and
I'm just like I think most people will
be fine
and I think the reality is I wouldn't
want to pull up Bill Maher and be like
bring on the recession to get rid of
trump
but I would want to say something like
guys whether you want it to or not the
storm is a bruin and we can see the
clouds off on the horizon whether it
comes now or whether it comes tomorrow
you best get ready for it but you know
what that storm is going to come and
wash away all of all this BS I've toyed
with the idea of let it get worse sooner
so that it can get better faster I don't
think it really works that way if you
let things get bad they get really bad
and out of control when things are out
of control the world economic Forum
creates a new government I'm not saying
to let things get out of control I'm
saying brace yourself for the storm